the former prosecutor on the case
declined to comment and Rice's original
defense attorney she died back in 2019.
now some people might see parallels
between this case and the story that we
told you about earlier today about not
Syed CNN anchor Jake Tapper and his
father first time a father-son I like it
Dr Ted Taffer joined us both at the
table welcome to you both first guys
Jake kudos to the article in the
Atlantic it's very long but it's such a
good read and I found just jaw-dropping
after jaw-dropping jaw-dropping moment
after one after another you say that
it's not up for you want readers to
decide about this case but you said what
happened after the case is not open for
argument what do you mean by that well
people my dad and I have our opinions
about whether or not CJ could have
physically done this and he'll talk
about that in a second but the idea that
he had legal representation worthy of
the name there's no dispute about that
he did not his lawyer was incompetent
his lawyer failed to visit the crime
scene his lawyer failed to bring up
basic facts about the case in trial such
as the fact that the only evidence
against CJ was this one witness this one
victim of the shooting who the night
before several times major testimony
several times she had no idea who shot
her no idea then overnight the police
say they got a confidential informant
tip those detectives investigating the
case go to see her with a photo lineup
all of a sudden she says it's CJ who did
it that's weak I mean for that to be the
only testimony against him that's weak
and nobody in and no police force would
charge any of us if that was the only
evidence against but here's a poor kid
with an incompetent attorney who didn't
even know to bring that up a poor black
kid poor black kid story unfortunate
absolutely I've heard many many times
and Dr Tapper you say physically can you
just show us briefly how he was walking
why you you're convinced that there's no
way he could have done this because why
CJ was 17 at the time 17 at the time he
was a strong healthy 17 year old from
South Philly yeah and when I saw him in
my office about five days before the
event yeah he had a lot of pain getting
from a sitting chair up to the exam
table and when the exam was done the
same thing in Reverse getting off the
exam table back to the chair and when he
left our there's an edge there I don't
want you yeah but I just want to show
how well that's the exam room
he was walking
like this shot up he had more than 30
Staples in his in his on his torso and a
fractured pelvis this is a healthy 17
year old and that's how he was walking
because Witnesses say the shooters ran
off sprinting away sprinting away so
physically so we we so rice is not
serving 30 to 60 years uh for attention
attempted murder the the Philadelphia
DA's office has a conviction Integrity
unit we reached out to them for a
statement and they told us in part uh
that they are not reviewing the case at
this time not because the conviction was
sound they say but a determination at
this time that there is insufficient
legal and factual basis to Warrant the
Commonwealth intervene intervening to
vacate the conviction so they're not
saying it was all good they're saying we
just don't have enough yet to go and
argue it why wasn't the shuffling and
the pelvis injury and the inability of
him to Sprint away more Central to the
defense there's probably two reasons for
that one is some of the evidence that we
now know wasn't people weren't aware of
at the time in 2011 when this event
occurred in 2013 almost a year and a
half later when the trial finally
occurred because she hadn't requested
the medical records in the hospital
right unbeknownst to everybody at the
time she was going through bankruptcy
proceedings taking on too many cases not
prioritizing this one is that the theory
she didn't even get the medical records
that showed that CJ had a fractured
pelvis you could Sprint if you have a
fracture so guys why is he still in jail
today this is this is what just made my
blood boil because why is he still in
jail that's the way the legal system
operates it protects itself right and
once you see it you can't unsee it the
the way to in Pennsylvania to appeal the
case to say the first step it's called
pcra to appeal it and say this wasn't a
fair case you go to the judge that
presided over the case how many judges
are going to say yeah you're right I did
a really crappy job yeah so and then
then the system protects itself it goes
to the next case the next level the
Supreme Court judges Tech judges right
now honestly it's in the hands of Larry
krasner the D.A who has this conviction
Integrity unit although he really only
takes on cases where there is full proof
evidence that this was a wrongful
conviction not look we don't think he
could have done it and he had a horrible
lawyer
um or it's up to the governor of
Pennsylvania or the people on the parole
board which include Federman and Shapiro
and Zach you talk about this flawed
system and the empty promise of the
sixth amendment yeah right to right to
legal counsel what needs to be done I
know it's a very loaded question yeah
what needs to be done we have a system
that again once you see it you can't
unsee it yeah we have a two-tiered
system of justice where people like us
are able to get good representation and
people who don't have means are not
right
um public defenders are usually pretty
good but they only see about 20 percent
of the cases of people that can't afford
it court-appointed attorneys are about
80 percent of those cases and they have
a far worse track record if we actually
are committed to criminal justice and
the sixth amendment worthy of the name
of standing for legal representation we
actually need to invest to make sure
that people
have a right to a good company
investment on the court appointed side
or just we need more public defenders
who are career people who are dedicating
their lives to that work it just needs
to be rethought because right now it's
it's failing and this is just one case
what's interesting about CJ's case that
you two are connected only that you're
connected to it so we're learning so
much thank you Tapper is the community
thank you for bringing dad to work today
oh yeah thank you thank you